doesn't America nothing is like pure I
think it was very left Co here in
Cleveland the hometown of Travis Kelce
he's holding a fashion show tonight I'm
hosting and we're gonna prank his older
brother Jason Kelsey because when Travis
is in the building
he's wildly unpredictable unlike the
wildly reliable auto and home insurance
of State Farm who happen to be
sponsoring this episode tonight you see
what I did there good
let's go ditch that playbook okay
Jason's on the move everybody let's go
you have a seat we want to watch the
monitors just patient man I don't get
nervous but I'm nervous right now
we told Jason to come upstairs because
he had to sign some merchandise before
the event Super Bowl champ you want some
wine okay I'll take some wine left ball
was just lost it right there
he is so clueless
we actually have like a bunch of things
that you need to sign this time just
because at the end we're gonna do an
auction yeah one of them is a Chiefs
Jersey that I've had for like four
months
and I got like Jerry Rice I got Justin
Timberlake Michael Jordan that was like
my thing for the event was I'll get all
these autographs for the one big thing
so I'll have you do that okay but I'm
gonna go to the bathroom back Eagles
legend Jason Kelsey this could get
really out of control
I cannot wait for her to do this this is
the money moment here we go
you got to take a look at this thing it
has a shot on it that is however
whenever you see it was a good moment
aren't open and go for it you try good
good she's so that's so perfect I don't
know that's a good luck Jason
I usually go you get there as soon as
possible all right let's do this
yes Frankie oh you're good brother no
I'm never gonna see Tim really did it
like did you spill it was a mistake I
think it was I mean nothing is like pure
I'm red is that what I do when I'm
auctioning off rose wine on New Jersey
did you even sign it yet just make it
all thanks for uh I mean this that was
literally the entire auction right there
on hand how poisonous up that was
literally the entire auction
you ruined it I mean
hi Jason will you sign it up
I don't know where you're gonna sign I
mean it's gonna run there's like just
one this let's just throw one on on
everything everyone it's officially a
home jersey you get the white spot real
stacks of one thing we're having
everyone is terrain IGP because on the
show ditch the PlayBook is district I
got pranked
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is what we had over here the entire
time we had the whole control room
watch it
I love that you said you're gonna buy I
can't wait for you to see your face
after like as soon as that happen you
gotta play
[Music]
what's up man is gonna win from the New
York Jets subscribe to bleacher report
on youtube or more distal PlayBook with
left go